los gehts und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video okay leute wo fangen
wir an in letzter zeit ist der
kommentarbereich bei mir so ein bisschen
eskaliert und müssen teilweise wirklich
so kommentare damals sie denkt was ist
eigentlich mit der welt bloß deswegen
hab ich mir gedacht machen wir heute mal
ein kommentare kommentieren video
prinzip ist eigentlich recht bekannt
deswegen legen wir jetzt los mit dem
ersten kommentar unter dem gestrigen
kultur video schreibt jonas thema ich
sagte jetzt kommen wieder die segel
schuhe und das ist eine sache die ich
nicht verstehe
mega viele leute schreiben so war es nie
diese band black eine milliarde 50-100
immer wenn ich segelschulen bio trage
was ich nicht verstehe
stefan richter kommentiert hinter dem
nachbarskinder video wie kommt sie die
hits ballack das ist so eine witzige
sache weil wir genau so immer über die
beiden jungs sind ja unsere nachbarskind
die haptischen daran gemerkt dass ich an
morley ankommt so gesagt habe wir tun
immer so als wenn es die krassesten
gangster würden so mega eskalieren
würden mega für drogen verdecken und
stellen bevor was sie machen will mir
die hatte gangster werden deswegen passt
dieser kommentar so gut er konnte kurz
rein dann feststelle wird darauf jetzt
mal replay vorn
wer will ich halten
es ist konzern so und zum thema ja
modern konzipierte nächste kommentar
rock tech schreibt der kleine blonde ist
ein crêpe gangster und leute ist aber
wirklich so die oscar den schon mal
gesagt jan konsti stick im business also
dieses nachbarskinder rassen aus videos
so viele geile kommentare bekommt der
nächste genau unter diesem video
nachbarskinder rassen aus von leonardo
308 der kleine war mega ruhig der andere
war auf druck
was soll ist drogba alter und darf so
wiederhole druck genauer er nach ghana
unter dem roulette video kommentiert
mika heine überhaupt nicht gegen den
kopf tritt mitte mai stellt mal vor das
hier ist die us billboard menschlich vor
dass ihr wäre okay im kopf von michael
heine lief das ganze land wollen wie
täuschen so an
und dann natürlich freut man sich auch
immer wieder deutlich wird youtube ist
ein freundlicher bereich ist ein
freundlicher raum wo sie übertreffen
zuschauer treffen alle haben sich lieb
alle schreiben sich gegenseitig nette
kommentare und deine frisur sieht aus
wie ein zug gebunden
sollte ich versuche einfach nur
irgendwie nicht vor die kamera zu
stellen und kann mich nicht mega zu
blamieren und dann schreibt einfach
irgend jemand so hettiger deine frisur
sieht aus wie ein zu gebundener müllsack
dankerode echt danke ich mich überhaupt
wegen dir
wisst ihr was leute wie mache jetzt
meine offizielle abstimmung bestimmt
jetzt mal den kommentaren ab jeder wenn
meine frisur gut findet schreibt hashtag
fried in die kommentare
und jeder meine frisur
scheiße findet schreibt hashtag müll
sagt in den kommentaren aber ja seid
ehrlich leute ich weiß schon wie das
ausgeredet ok leitung jetzt kommen wir
zu mathematik mit spaß dusche apps
youtube plus auto ist gleich scheiß
angeber das leid der zweifach ist
mathematik in dem fall einen youtube
oder ein auto knapp den scheiß
angebracht seht ihr dass hier leute das
hier essen scheiß angeber
diese logik so einfach jeder youtuber
den autor des apache angeber wenn ich
jetzt raus gebe mir keine ahnung für 200
euro ein auto mit einer million
kilometer kaufe natürlich immer noch ein
youtube der sich ein auto kaufen ist
einfach scheiß angebracht und dann
gibt's natürlich auch solche klassiker
wie von crans bei unserem youtube
dokumentiert wird wie chris und dann
natürlich leute alter es so krass ab
unter der e mail exchange kam soviel
kommentare wie die umgebende brusthaare
du hast mehr bewusst habe als ich auf
dem kopf stehen regale vorfinden
ich liebe
hmm lecker tun als hätten den kommentar
nicht gewesen übrigens sollte schreibt
meine kommentare wir das ganze set up zu
finden
ich habe einen zeug polster da und ich
habe sogar meinen studien gestellt und
einen motorradhelm aufgestellt die mega
brände maus ist es auch aber sonst hat
man dabei von jetzt leute zum ende der
absolute absolute bringer und zwar ein
secret schreibt unter dem roulette video
kann ich euch allen einen blasen heute
also wohlgemerkt in dem video waren max
ich und luca und 1 sieg und einfach mit
einem funky marienkäfer als profilbild
einfach kann ich euch allen ein blasen
oder wird sollte ich auch wenn ich im
kommentar so kurz davor einen kanal zu
löschen ich war schon die üblichen
kommentar gesehen dachte mir so oscar
klicken rechts auf das youtube banner
klick auf einem kanal
vielleicht will ich selber machen sollen
so läuft es von meinem ersten kommentar
kommentaren das war zu einem ersten
kommentar kommentieren video und ich
muss sagen ich war ein bisschen nervös
irgendwie ich weiß nicht wer schon mal
ein bisschen der röslau vor einer kamera
zu stehen links zum zocken dazu haben
steht eine frontale die kameraleute ich
versuche momentan so ein bisschen meinen
content abzuwechseln
und ich hier früher amt zu bringen ihr
müsst die idl walter deswegen würde es
nicht interessieren was erwartet schreib
doch einfach in die kommentare